Let's consider an example
of motion, in which we want
to use our energy concepts.
So suppose we have a ramp
which is circular, radius r.
And we have an object here.
And now, here's a surface
a certain distance,
d, that has friction, where
the coefficients of friction
is non-uniform.
So we'll write it mu-0 And
we'll write it as mu-1x.
We'll take x equals zero.
And then here, there's
a spring and a wall.
And here there is no friction.
Now as we drop, assuming we
have enough height here, h,
so that this block will
slide across the friction,
make it all the way across and
start compressing its spring.
What I'd like to
find is how much
the spring has been compressed.
OK, now how do we analyze this?
Well the key is to use
our energy principle,
where we have w-external
equals the change
in mechanical energy.
And the key is to,
what we're going
to do is the tool that
we're going to use
is what we call energy
diagrams for the initial.
So what does this mean?
We want to choose, we
want to first identify
the initial and final states
that we're referring to.
So, in our picture, here
is our initial state.
And I'll draw the final state
in when the spring has been
compressed a distance, x-final.
So I drew it on my diagram.
So we have initial
and final states.
And now what we
want to do is choose
reference points,
zero-points, zero-point
for each potential function.
And show that on our diagram.
So for the potential
energy of gravity, here,
if we chose this to be
y, then this y equals 0.
And u at y equals 0 is 0.
And we'll call that the
zero point for gravity.
And the zero point
for the spring
is when this x, now I'm going
to call here x equals 0.
So, let's call this a variable,
I can call it anything I want.
I'll call it u-final.
And this is where u is zero.
So u-final just measures
the stretch of the spring.
And so at y equals 0 is 0.
And u spring little
u equal 0, 0.
So now I can
identify my energies.
So let's talk about
the initial energy
is all gravitational potential.
That's mgy.
It's starting at rest.
And e-final well, here,
this is the distance
where it comes to rest, also.
So there's no final
kinetic energy.
There's no gravitational
potential energy,
because we're on the
surface at y equals 0.
But our spring has
been compressed
by 1/2 k little-u-final square.
Now, in terms of
our external work
equals the change in
mechanical energy,
we have now identified
the right-hand side
using these tools of
the energy diagrams.
And I can write my description
u-final squared, minus mgy.
Now what I have to do is
think about the friction
force, f kinetic friction,
as the object moves.
This friction force
is non-uniform.
If we were to draw n, and mg,
then our friction force here
is equal to the integral minus
the integral from x equals 0,
to x equals d.
Equals 0 to x equal d,
of the friction force,
which is equal to the
coefficient of friction, ukndx.
Now that 0 to d, notice that
our coefficient of friction
is varying.
And I chose it intentionally
to show you that friction
is really an integral.
So we have mu-0 plus mu-1 xmgdx.
Let's put our integration
variable in there.
And these are just two
separate integrals.
The first one is easy.
It's minus mu-0 mgd.
And the second one is -mu-1 mg.
And we're just integrating
x-prime, dx prime
between 0 and d.
So that's simply
d-squared over 2.
And that's equal to
ku-final squared minus mgy.
Let's write that as y-initial.
And we're starting it
at y-initial equals h.
And so, even though
this is complicated,
I can now solve for how much
this spring has been compressed
with a little bit of algebra.
And so I'm just going to
bring a bunch of terms
over to the other side.
And take the square root of 2,
divided by k of mgy-initial.
Minus mu-0 mgd.
Minus mu-1 mgd-squared over 2.
And that's how much the
spring is compressed.
Notice what I did not
do was divide this up
into a bunch of
different motions.
I picked an initial state.
I picked a final state.
I drew my energy diagrams
with my zero points.
I described the key parameters
of initial and final states,
y-i and u-final.
I defined the initial
mechanical energy,
the final mechanical energy.
And then applied
the work energy,
work mechanical
energy principle.
I had to integrate the
friction force because it
was non-trivial and solve
for how much the spring has
been compressed.